not okay
today Kim Kardashian in tears seemingly
over her exes Pete Davidson and Kanye
West we you know have always stayed true
to who we are and always shared pretty
much everything so that's just who we've
been Kim's laying it all out there on
season three of the Kardashians the
emotional moments teased in this just
dropped trailer I don't even know where
we left off we were still in a
relationship I was yep
damn
things change really quickly yeah when
we last Saw Kim on the show she was
dating Pete Davidson
like so cute
yeah he's just super genuine babe yeah
do you want to shower with me really
quick
what just happened I love that he's kind
yeah and really really thoughtful and I
love the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet
she said the chemistry I was like okay
chemistry chemistry well that chemistry
fizzled out and in the sneak peek Kim
breaks down you okay
um not okay
today while she doesn't name names Kim
appears to be upset over her ex-husband
and the father of her four children
Kanye West who since the last season
aired made headlines for wearing a white
lives matter shirt at Paris fashion week
and made several anti-semitic comments
on social media the thing about it me
and Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me I don't know how Kim
handles everything with her ex-husband I
don't think you realize the weight of
the world is on your shoulders he has
made up the most insane narrative we
stay silent through all the lies for my
kids all that Echoes what Kim said last
year on the IRL podcast you know it's
hard it's like co-parenting it's really
hard if I'm in a petty Moon
I'll go back and I'll be like okay I
have all the receipts you know but then
I go back to my babies
and I think they will see if they'll
feel my energy Kim and yay finalized
their divorce last November after six
years of marriage and she got candid
about shielding her kids from the
controversy criticism and negative press
directed at their dad I definitely
protected him and I still will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids so in my
home my kids don't know anything that
goes on on the outside world now a
source tells ET that things between Kim
and Kanye are fine enough and she does
her best to maintain a good co-parenting
relationship with him adding that Kim
just wants to move forward and be happy
you just gotta roll with it and when it
comes to love she wants the next person
she dates to be stable supportive loving
and consistent across the board that
would be my goal that would be the
ultimate dream those words also describe
Kim's famous fam our source says they're
all encouraging her to get back out
there again everyone just wants her to
be happy and continue to succeed in all
ways
[Music]
thank you